ciel du Jura
des éclairs déchirent le ciel
sur cette autre vidéo le tonnerre
transperce la nuit vous êtes le coyote
de Tex Avery vous savez il court il
court il a franchi la falaise et sous
lui c'est le vide il a découvre il
découvre ce vide et soudain il chute
dans le Tarn-et-Garonne un début de
tornade se forme dans les nuages le
coyote de Tex Avery est comique lui vous
êtes vous tragique vous êtes des dangers
oui des dangers pour les Français et
nous sommes à la veille de la huitième
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites et les blocages se
poursuivent dans plusieurs villes de
France comme vous le voyez vous n'avez
pas pu vous empêcher de succomber
finalement vos péchés
et la volonté de vouloir prendre une
hauteur que vous n'atteindrez jamais
c'est pas le droit demain
on considère toujours que c'est une
journée noire mais quand je regarde
l'image d'ensemble on sera pas dans des
niveaux de perturbation dans les
transports publics comme on a connu
certains jours de mobilisation on parle
de l'ensemble des leaders syndicaux
devant l'Assemblée
nationale pour s'exprimer on se on
discute ensemble c'est bien quand on
continue de d'annoncer ensemble les
choses dans les règles dans lesquelles
on s'était fixé de le faire je regrette
un peu ce matin que que cette annonce
qui sortent alors qu'on a pas décidé de
la faire encore et donc cette réforme
elle est catastrophique pour le pays
elle va conduire beaucoup de Français
dans la trappe à pauvreté entre 62 et 64
ce sera des gens au RSA et je me pose
toutes mes forces à cette réforme est-ce
qu'il faut que la commission mixte
paritaire
ne soit pas à huis clos comme le réclame
Boris Vallot comme président du groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée je comprends
qu'il le demande mais il y a des règles
et je pense que c'est à la
constitutionnel de le rappeler il me
semble que c'est la moindre des choses
que cette commission mixte paritaire
elle soit publique et que ça ne se passe
pas dans un huis clos secret avec des
arrangements des cuisine et des
magouilles on en parlement en France qui
heureusement je le dis pour tous les
partis politiques fonctionnent de
manière transparente donc je voudrais
pas qu'on alimente les tests sur
lesquels il y aurait des espèces
d'agenda cachés
encore une fois qui en décide un café
croissant à côté d'une montagne de
déchets
des rues devenues des dépotoirs en une
semaine le visage de Paris s'est
transformé welcome Paris
to présence oh vie la lumière do you
want baguette my friend do you no madame
Hidalgo je vous dis mon soutien total
entier à ce mouvement social et lorsque
cela concerne en plus des catégories de
personnels de la Fonction publique et du
secteur privé je dis au gouvernement
déjà parlé avec eux
déjà essayé de comprendre ce qui sont en
train de vous dire quand il y a une
grève dans une ville il y a une question
de santé publique et de salubrité
publique c'est pas la grève des éboueurs
qui me pense tellement problème c'est
que c'est un Hidalgo qui fait grève
elle-même elle ne fait rien normalement
le sixième arrondissement est géré par
la régie publique des éboueurs de Paris
mais cette nuit c'est une entreprise
privée la société Derichebourg qui est
intervenue devant notre caméra les
éboueurs ne sont pas très à l'aise
et hallucinant c'est que c'est action 0
et silence radio il a fallu que
j'interpelle la mère de Paris et que
d'autres députés ou merde arrondissement
le fasse pour que au bout de 8 jours il
y a une expression publique merde
arrondissement géré par la régie
municipale en matière de propreté
demande d'intervention d'une société
privée en désencombrer les rues c'est
une file la mère de Paris qui prend la
décision
je souhaite que l'État dans ce cas là
prenne ses responsabilités en raison de
la carence de la mère de Paris et de
l'irresponsabilité de Madame Amy dalgo
et de ses adjoints il faut reprendre
Paris en moi et nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui victimes de l'entêtement du
gouvernement donc la situation elle est
tout à fait déplorable nous la
regrettons profondément et je redis
notre mobilisation absolue avec les
moyens qui sont à notre disposition pour
en gérer les excès un peu facile quand
j'entends des élus de Paris dire tout ça
et la faute de la réforme c'est aussi le
fait qu'ils ont eux-mêmes encouragé à la
grève et que c'est une façon de se
défausser de leur responsabilité compte
tenu du niveau de gréviste nous ne
peuvent nous pouvons avoir que des
mesures palliatives au regard des enjeux
du ramassage des ordures ménagères la
décision de la Cour d'appel de Paris est
tombée ce matin l'humoriste qui a
provoqué un grave accident de la route
sous l'emprise de drogue Grèce de sous
contrôle judiciaire il a donc
interdiction de quitter l'hôpital où il
se trouve